[Music]  here's the ball in the hopefully this is  everything and make you guys it's the  possible of course other moments to let  you speak about we're gonna try to take  him game by game and do our best to win  and here is your roommate away game  it was Jeannie well okay so Monica  before a game who's the DJ who puts the  music on it was Adam sometimes I'm right  but now we have new DJ Van Dyke is it  good  depends sometimes good sometimes good  who is the fastest player at Liverpool  and can you sing the money money okay  let's move on let's move on last  question the big man comes on the pitch  at the end what is it like to receive a  Jurgen Klopp hug what does it feel like  can you show me what it's like what he  does when he comes on the pitch  [Applause]  you